boris johnson's visit to astrazeneca's
macclesfield plant
is clearly a confident shot in the arm
for the vaccine producer
more concerns have been raised in europe
over its possible
link to blood clots but the prime
minister
insisting again that this vaccine
is safe on the uh the astrozenica the
oxygen astrazeneca
vaccine i think that the best thing
people should do is
is look at what the uh the hra
say our independent regulator that's
that's why we have them that's why
they're
uh they're independent and their advice
to people is to
uh you know keep going out there get
your get your jab get your second jab
very very important but despite the
prime minister's insistence and the
vaccine
safety there will be more doubt after
oxford university announced
it is pausing a small clinical trial of
the vaccine
in children in a statement it said
we await additional information from the
mhra
on its review of rare cases of
thrombosis
thrombocytopenia that have been reported
in adults before giving any further
vaccinations in the trial
the decision is bound to raise further
concerns but i was told
it does not mean the vaccine is not safe
to use
it's clear that clotting disorders are a
common side effect or a common
consequence of covert 19 disease
much commoner with the disease than
could could possibly be the case
with the numbers we're seeing on the due
to the vaccine
if you want to avoid getting a clotting
disorder you don't want to get covered
19 you're much better off getting the
vaccine
and you're much better off getting it
sooner rather than later
the doubts over the oxford vaccine
safety are not widespread
it is still seen as a way for some
normality
to return to our pandemic limited lives
i just want to get back to normal so if
it's safe to take um
i'm happy to have it and uh yeah get
back to normal i just want the vaccine
and i don't really care which one i get
to be honest
um yeah i had to get happy to get any of
them really
it feels like i could just slow it down
to reduce it because of a
rather slow rather small number of cases
we need to get back to normal
and the vaccine is going to help that
happen we've been warned that the
vaccine rollout
might be lumpy at times it is certainly
slowing down right now you can see here
the number of first doses administered
through march
comes down significantly each week
government advisors now predict we will
only be able to administer 2.7 million
doses
per week until the end of july
this figure is significantly less than
previous estimates
and it means there is little surplus for
first doses
after second doses have been
administered
but the slowdown has not dented the
government's confidence
about meeting its ambitious vaccination
targets
that will eventually bring us out of
lockdown
joshi sky news